three flowers bloomed yesterday and they
draw the flowers one two three six more
bloom today one two three four five six
how many flowers bloomed
well three yesterday six more today so
you're going to have the three from
yesterday plus the six more today
well what's three plus six equal to well
three plus six is the same thing as six
plus three and that's going to be nine
six plus one is seven six plus two is
eight
6 plus 3 is 9 and it's good to know just
in your head 6 plus 3 is 9 3 plus 6 is 9
or you could even count them one two
three four five six seven eight nine
let's do another one
there were two sharks one two three more
sharks came one two three how many
sharks are there now
well there's the two that were there
before plus the three that came so
there's now two plus three sharks well
what is two plus three well two plus
three is five two plus three is five and
you could count it one two three four
five let's do one more
a squirrel picked up seven acorns one
two three four five six seven she picked
up one more acorn find out how many
acorns she picked up well she picked up
the seven plus one acorn so it's going
to be seven plus one acorns and that is
equal to eight one two three four five
six seven eight we got it right